[Music]
right um ever thought we could do with
leftover croissants well trust me i have
the perfect breakfast brunch or even
sweet treat recipe that is definitely a
crowd pleaser a delicious croissant
french toast in literally 10 minutes
right oscar pan down please young man
croissants they're
24 hours old okay a little bit firmer
nothing wrong with that uh beautiful
apples
a little bit of custard left over eggs
demoral sugar butter touch of tartness
creme fresh a little bit of honey
cinnamon and some powdered sugar
right let's get 10 minutes on the plot
for this delicious
sweet treats
now
hands on
don't get them too hot but get them hot
enough okay on
i like to use frying pans non-stick
preferably
first things first get your batter ready
eggs
in
okay and i want this sort of
quite thick
i like it to be somewhat
a really nice way of coating
a quest on
so whisk up the eggs
a little touch of milk in there just a
tiny drop okay
and then literally
whisk that up
now
here's where the magic starts
take the quest on
and just put your knife in there and
twist with a point
you know inside those croissants when
you slice inside these there's lots of
holes right and that's because of the
sort of
yeast
the way the layers work in a croissant
put your knife in
get your custard
into a squeezy bottle put the nozzle in
and squeeze and basically all we're
doing is turning left
turning right
and filling up
that croissant
now
as it starts to fill up you feel the
weight of this croissant get a little
bit heavier
in and it comes and seeps up through the
top
again in
down squeeze turn left
turn right come back up to the middle
and literally count to three
and pull out okay
touch more boom got this nice weighted
custard lined croissant
now so far so good pan nice and hot we
move quickly on these things you have to
be super careful that you don't overdo
it
get your apples
okay and this is just a very simple
delicious way of serving
a sort of
lazy brunch
lunch
i like the sort of apple chunks i don't
like cut them too small i like them sort
of a little bit robust
also
the flavor
of these granny smith are beautiful
sometimes you can make the apples the
day before so they sort of stew
overnight in the fridge
delicious now
what i'm trying to do here is make a
very sort of quick toffee apple
okay
in
we're gonna run two pans at the same
time
apples go in to the little pan
whack up that gas
after that i'm gonna sprinkle
my brown sugar and form a really nice
caramel on there okay
now let that caramelize
be very careful because it gets very
very hot
the secret of a great caramel is the
butter
okay
butter goes in
apples are getting caramelized but i'd
like just a little touch
of cinnamon in there okay that's going
to make that sort of
a little bit more spicier
cinnamon in
now mix that up
a little touch of salt
a salted caramel
beautifully done
butter and look we got toffee apples now
and that cinnamon smells incredible
give that a nice mix be careful when you
flip it once that sugar dissolves
this is how you turn it into something
toffee get a nice spoon
a creme fraiche
goes in and that creates this really
nice tartness to that caramel
bring that back up to the boil
turn that down
and let that cran fresh
melt
and also you've got these beautiful
nice light glazed toffee apples right
now for that incredible
french toast croissant in
and sort of push it down
and manipulate it in
now
time please
thank you right touch of olive oil there
just a smidgen okay
a little bit of butter in there just a
touch
that stops the butter from burning
in
roll
and
on
in
push it down let it absorb that amazing
egg
don't squash it too much otherwise the
custard will come out in
and there you go beautiful
now
lightly see that custard on top
my apples are sat there
i can make them a little bit more
delicious just with a little spoon
of wild honey in there and that gives
another added sweetness
but
look at that beautiful now
gas back up
first one turn over
beautiful
beautiful
and it's almost like a sort of uh quick
sort of fast track take on an eggy bread
except we've got the sweetness of the
custard on the side that beautiful egg
and then look oh my goodness me
that's so beautiful
there we go that can sit now in the
caramel the flavor that is
delicious
now
once you've got the color
on the croissants turn them on the side
and cook on the side as well you want
that
custard stain in the middle
time please
[Music]
get it nice and crispy that's the secret
behind eggy bread isn't it getting it
all nice and crispy i've got enough heat
in the pan literally
90 seconds each side up
and out that one sits there
that one rolls over
don't forget we still got the magic of
the custard in there and that sits there
now
the apples
take the apples i said to this almost
like a sort of
a glazed
spicy
toffee apple
and then when you cut into that
croissant you've got that wonderful
custard
and then look
i'll just drizzle some of that toffee
it's too good do not throw that away and
then finally
i like to mix
the cinnamon
in with the powdered sugar
and then we just tap
tap
tap
and literally
i should rename this book
brunch in eight minutes because
there we have a beautiful fast track
take on eggy bread
with toffee apples
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay
intent cookbook inspired by this series
and trust me you're gonna come out a
much better chef and if you like this
video don't forget to subscribe to my
amazing youtube channel for more good
luck